من اخبارنا الاخرى دانت او ادانت محكمه
باكستانيه خاصه كلا من رئيس الوزراء
الاسبق عمران خان ووزير خارجيته شاه محمود
قريشي بتهمه تسريب اسرار للدوله وحكمت
المحكمه على خان وقريش بالسجن عشر سنوات
لكل منهما معنا من اسلام اباد مدير مكتب
الجزيره عبد الرحمن مطر عبد الرحمن تفاصيل
اوفى وايضا على اي اساس بنت المحكمه
قرارها
طبعا المحكمه بنت هذا القرار على ان عمران
خان تحدث علنا وفي اكثر من مناسبه عن فحوى
هذه الرساله التي حملها السفير الباكستاني
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لحكومته
هنا في اسلام اباد عن لقاء جمعه مع احد
المسؤولين الكبار في الخارجيه الامريكيه
طبعا عمران خان كان تحدث اكثر من مره
وبشكل عا علني في حشود جماهيريه وحتى في
مقابلات متلفزه هنا في باكستان عن ان هذه
الرساله التي وصلته عندما كان رئيسا
للوزراء من سفير باكستان في الولايات
المتحده كانت تحمل تفاصيل مؤامره امريكيه
للتعاون بين واشنطن وعدد من معارضي خان
هنا في باكستان للاطاحه بحكومته هذه
التفاصيل التي تحدث عنها عمران خان اكثر
من مره وبشكل العلني هي التي دفعت الاداره
اداره الدوله هنا في باكستان لرفع هذه
الدعوه القضائيه ضد عمران خان وضد وزير
خارجيته شعب محمود قرشي وحقيقه بعد سلسله
من المداولات وايام طويله من التفاصيل
والاستماع لكثير من الشهود من بينهم حتى
السفير الامريكي الذي كان يومها سفيرا
لباكستان لدى الولايه المتحده خرجت
المحكمه اليوم بهذا الحكم الذي نطقت به
قبل قليل و بشكل مختصر وادانت فيه عمران
خان وشاه محمود قرشي وزير خارجيته وايضا
حكمت عليهما بالسجن لعشر سنوات لكل منهما
بتهمه انهما ا افشاء اسرار دوله وهذا
مخالف للقوانين المعمول بها ومخالف لمواد
الدستور التي تحظر على المسؤولين
الحكوميين كشف اسرار الدوله والرسائل
السريه المتداوله ضمن الحكومه وايضا مع
السفرات الباكستانيه في الخارج لذا تمت
ادانه عمران خان اليوم عبد الرحمن مطر
مدير مكتب الجزيره كنت معنا من اسلام مباد
شكرا جزيلا لك